After all the work we've been
doing with fluids, you
probably have a pretty good
sense of what pressure is.
Now let's think a little bit
about what it really means,
especially when we think
about it in terms
of a gas in a volume.
Remember, what was
the difference
between a gas and a liquid?
They're both fluids, they both
take the shape of their
containers, but a gas is
compressible, while a liquid
is incompressible.
Let's start focusing on gases.
Let's say I have a container,
and I have a
bunch of gas in it.
What is a gas made of?
It's just made up of a whole
bunch of the molecules of the
gas itself, and I'll draw each
of the molecules with a little
dot-- it's just going to have
a bunch of molecules in it.
There's many, many, many more
than what I've drawn, but
that's indicative, and they'll
all be going in random
directions-- this one might be
going really fast in that
direction, and that one might
be going a little bit slower
in that direction.
They all have their own little
velocity vectors, and they're
always constantly bumping into
each other, and bumping into
the sides of the container, and
ricocheting here and there
and changing velocity.
In general, especially at this
level of physics, we assume
that this is an ideal gas, that
all of the bumps that
occur, there's no
loss of energy.
Or essentially that they're all
elastic bumps between the
different molecules.
There's no loss of momentum.
Let's keep that in mind, and
everything you're going to see
in high school and on the AP
test is going to deal with
ideal gases.
Let's think about what pressure
means in this context.
A lot of what we think about
pressure is something pushing
on an area.
If we think about pressure
here-- let's pick
an arbitrary area.
Let's take this side.
Let's take this surface
of its container.
Where's the pressure
going to be
generated onto this surface?
It's going to be generated by
just the millions and billions
and trillions of little
bumps every time-- let
me draw a side view.
If this is the side view of the
container, that same side,
every second there's always
these little molecules of gas
moving around.
If we pick an arbitrary period
of time, they're always
ricocheting off of the side.
We're looking at time over a
super-small fraction of time.
And over that period of time,
this one might end up here,
this one maybe bumped into it
right after it ricocheted and
came here, this one changes
momentum and goes like that.
This one might have already been
going in that direction,
and that one might ricochet.
But what's happening is, at
any given moment, since
there's so many molecules,
there's always going to be
some molecules that
are bumping into
the side of the wall.
When they bump, they have
a change in momentum.
All force is change in
momentum over time.
What I'm saying is that in any
interval of time, over any
period or any change in time,
there's just going to be a
bunch of particles that are
changing their momentum on the
side of this wall.
That is going to generate force,
and so if we think
about how many on average--
because it's hard to keep
track of each particle
individually, and when we did
kinematics and stuff, we'd keep
track of the individual
object at play.
But when we're dealing with
gases and things on a macro
level, you can't keep track of
any individual one, unless you
have some kind of unbelievable
supercomputer.
We can say, on average, this
many particles are changing
momentum on this wall in
this amount of time.
And so the force exerted on this
wall or this surface is
going to be x.
If we know what that force is,
and we you know the area of
the wall, we can figure out
pressure, because pressure is
equal to force divided
by area.
What does this help us with?
I wanted to give you that
intuition first, and now I'm
just going to give you the one
formula that you really just
need to know in thermodynamics.
And then as we go into the next
few videos, I'll prove to
you why it works, and
hopefully give
you more of an intuition.
Now you understand, hopefully,
what pressure means in the
context of a gas
in a container.
With that out of the way, let
me give you a formula.
I hope by the end of this video
you have the intuition
for why this formula works.
In general, if I have an ideal
gas in a container, the
pressure exerted on the gas-- on
the side of the container,
or actually even at any point
within the gas, because it
will all become homogeneous at
some point-- and we'll talk
about entropy in future videos--
but the pressure in
the container and on its
surface, times the volume of
the container, is equal
to some constant.
We'll see in future videos that
that constant is actually
proportional to the average
kinetic energy of the
molecules bouncing around.
That should make sense to you.
If the molecules were moving
around a lot faster, then you
would have more kinetic energy,
and then they would be
changing momentum on the sides
of the surface a lot more, so
you would have more pressure.
Let's see if we can get a little
bit more intuition onto
why pressure times volume
is a constant.
Let's say I have a container
now, and it's got a bunch of
molecules of gas in it.
Just like I showed you in that
last bit right before I
erased, these are bouncing
off of the sides
at a certain rate.
Each of the molecules might
have a different kinetic
energy-- it's always changing,
because they're always
transferring momentum
to each other.
But on average, they all have
a given kinetic energy, they
keep bumping at a certain rate
into the wall, and that
determines the pressure.
What happens if I were able to
squeeze the box, and if I were
able to decrease the
volume of the box?
I just take that same box with
the same number of molecules
in it, but I squeeze.
I make the volume of
the box smaller--
what's going to happen?
I have the same number of
molecules in there, with the
same kinetic energy, and on
average, they're moving with
the same velocities.
So now what's going to happen?
They're going to be hitting the
sides more often-- at the
same time here that this
particle went bam, bam, now it
could go bam, bam, bam.
They're going to be hitting
the sides more often, so
you're going to have more
changes in momentum, and so
you're actually going to have
each particle exert more force
on each surface.
Because it's going to be hitting
them more often in a
given amount of time.
The surfaces themselves
are smaller.
You have more force on a
surface, and on a smaller
surface, you're going to
have higher pressure.
Hopefully, that gives you an
intuition that if I had some
amount of pressure in this
situation-- if I squeeze the
volume, the pressure
increases.
Another intuition-- if
I have a balloon,
what blows up a balloon?
It's the internal air pressure
of the helium, or your own
exhales that you put
into the balloon.
The more and more you try to
squeeze a balloon-- if you
squeeze it from all directions,
it gets harder and
harder to do it, and that's
because the pressure within
the balloon increases as you
decrease the volume.
If volume goes down, pressure
goes up, and that makes sense.
That follows that when they
multiply each other, you have
to have a constant.
Let's take the same example
again, and what happens if you
make the volume bigger?
Let's say I have-- it's huge
like that, and I should have
done it more proportionally, but
I think you get the idea.
You have the same number of
particles, and if I had a
particle here, in some period
of time it could have gone
bam, bam, bam-- it could have
hit the walls twice.
Now, in this situation, with
larger walls, it might just go
bam, and in that same amount
of time, it will maybe get
here and won't even hit
the other wall.
The particles, on average, are
going to be colliding with the
wall less often, and the walls
are going to have a larger
area, as well.
So in this case, when our volume
goes up, the average
pressure or the pressure in
the container goes down.
Hopefully, that gives you a
little intuition, and so
you'll never forget
that pressure
times volume is constant.
And then we can use that to do
some pretty common problems,
which I'll do in
the next video.
I'm about to run out of time.
See you soon.